did you know that you could make
hundreds of thousands and even millions
of dollars by partnering with brands
online did you know that one of the
rising areas as a content creator is
being a micro influencer and actually a
recent article came out that said in the
year 2022 it's an estimated that micro
influencers will make
16.4
billion
dollars by partnering with brands online
if you are like me and you're seeing
that number and are thinking i would
like a piece of that 16.4 billion
dollars then this exclusive training is
the right opportunity for you i'm
excited to bring a special guest here to
our inner circle if you're watching live
on youtube right now we are streaming
one of our exclusive online membership
programs to you so you can get a taste
of what it's like inside of our think
media membership called inner circle now
today's special guest is justin moore
and let me just tell you a little bit
about
now justin
uh justin is a sponsorship coach and the
founder of creative wizard a school and
community that teaches you how to find
and negotiate very key your dream brand
deals so that you stop leaving thousands
on the table along with his wife april
he has been a full-time content creator
for over seven years and his personality
and and he has personally made over
three million dollars working with
brands because of his personality also
as you'll see he has also run an
influencer marketing agency for over
five years that has helped other
creators earn an additional two million
dollars justin brings a very unique
perspective because not only has he been
a creator in this in the trenches with
us just like you and me doing
sponsorships for years but by also
running an agency and getting a larger
landscape of the entire industry he is
an insider knowledge
is insider knowledge behind how big
brands choose their influencers that
they want to partner with he's going to
be sharing those secrets with you today
and he also can help you uh learn when
to pass up deals i know that sounds hard
but we're gonna share why that's
important today as well justin's mission
is to enable creators big and small to
land one million dollars in paid brand
spartan partnerships by
2032. and i am so excited to have him
here in our inner circle today to teach
you of in our community as well as here
on youtube so make sure you like that um
like the youtube video and let's bring
on justin justin how you doing what's
going on heather i'm stoked to be here
i'm bringing the energy on uh what is it
thursday um it's gonna be a blast i love
talking about sponsorships and uh by the
end of this session your mind is gonna
be blown because you will be
ready to go and pitch your dream brand
it's so exciting you know um i will have
to admit can i make a confession real
quick justin
okay um at first when we started think
media i was like anti-brand deals i was
like why do we need to work with other
people we can make our own content you
know let's just buy the things oh it's
such a headache to work with people and
then
i start the the
uh the veil was the up and i was like oh
my goodness we started working with
brands and we were partnering with some
incredible people and the dollar started
to roll in and because of brand deals
we've been able to make multiple seven
figures in our company which has
afforded us the opportunity to build a
team to save money in our business to
give generously to um places that we
love and it's just an incredible
experience to partner with other
companies share what they're doing but
also share that uniquely with your own
audience so i will say i'm a believer in
brand deals uh and i know that you've
worked with uh creators like me who have
been resistant to it but then actually
see that there's a benefit on the other
side
well you know what we're going to get
into that today and honestly it is a big
mindset shift because you know when you
go from thinking like oh working with
brands is such a pain in the butt to
this is actually going to be a
win-win-win yeah i'm gonna get some
money which is great but you know this
brand you know it's gonna be a great
collaboration for them they're gonna be
very happy but that third piece which is
often missing is that my audience is
gonna get so much out of this they're
gonna find out about a product or a
service or a software solution that you
know helps their take their business to
the next level or it helps them in their
personal life so um that mindset shift
is really critical and i'm stoked to
talk about that today all right well i'm
gonna uh
leave the floor to you and um and i'm
excited we will do q a after this if you
have any questions make sure that you
post them inside of the chat i will star
them and then i'll come back on justin
and we'll get to a q a part
sounds good looking forward to it
so uh thanks so much everyone again my
name is justin moore and we're talking
all we're going to be talking all about
how to craft a sponsorship pitch that no
brand will ignore okay let me know drop
it in the chat if you're excited about
this let me know your questions we're
going to be talking about it at the end
of this um but let me start by sharing
uh an email that my wife april and i
received a few years ago it said hey
justin great news we're approved to move
forward with our harmony of the seas
opportunity we're excited to have you on
board our barcelona ship sailing june
5th to the 7th
and our launch sale in november in fort
lauderdale to explore the newest ship to
the royal caribbean family now
we're talking 18 decks
15 restaurants a crew of 2100 people to
run it and there is one person by the
way whose entire job is to sharpen the
ice skates for the ice rink oh
and one more thing
the ultimate abyss a ten-story
waterslide now
for my wife april and i this was an
absolute dream sponsorship they were
flying us to spain
to check out their new ship
you're probably thinking
well how the heck did you get
that opportunity
well in order to tell you that story and
to teach you
how to get opportunities like that we
have to go back to the beginning because
when i started out pitching brands as a
creator i sent messages that looked like
this
right drop it in the chat have you ever
sent a pitch like that oh you know i
love your brand want to collaborate
right let me know let me know in the
chat right this is a this is a safe
space so it's okay it's all right okay
so back in 2009 when we first started on
youtube influencer marketing quote
unquote that was not a thing right and
just as a quick reminder of what was
happening in the world
in 2009 okay the most popular phone in
the world was the iphone 3g
okay which you could use to call your
friends to ask them what time you were
going to the theater to see the brand
new movie avatar
and then when you got home from the
movie you'd boot up your computer to
watch the most popular youtubers in the
world ryan higa
smosh
and fred
drop it in the chat anyone remember
anyone watch these you know watch these
guys back in the day right this was
early early youtube
okay and even though i had an incredibly
promising career as a makeup artist
after doing the boyfriend does my makeup
challenge right that looks pretty that
looks pretty decent right let me know in
the chat what do you think makeup artist
maybe not
right i begged and i pleaded with my
wife april and i said at the time she
was my girlfriend fiance and i said
let me get us some discounts for our
honeymoon
we had around uh 29 000 subscribers on
youtube
at that time but i was convinced that
someone would see the value in giving us
free stuff in exchange for promo on our
channel you know april was pretty
skeptical but you know bless her heart
she basically said knock yourself out
right
and so this is a dramatic reenactment of
me in my cubicle this is not me but you
know i had a nine-to-five job right and
i was emailing hundreds of hotels in
thailand which is where we wanted to go
and when i say hundreds
i mean hundreds okay and i was i was
feeling pretty good about my chances
right i mean someone is gonna jump at
this marketing slash business
opportunity
right i just i look back on these emails
and i just laugh because it's just like
the wording i use is just so funny to me
but
it was a rude awakening when honestly at
that time a bunch of my messages got
sent back as undeliverable
right to add insult to injury when i
actually did get a response it was it
was no thanks not interested
or actually honestly the worst of all
the salt is just rubbing in my wounds
was just the crickets
right look come on at least respond and
tell me no
right
so
by the end of that week things were
not going well
but then
something interesting happened
a hotel called paradise ko yao
in phuket thailand
responded
they'd give us
the romantic candlelight dinner under
the palms the spa treatment for lovers
and my personal favorite
the tropical island picnic even though
the beach was kind of dirty and all we
had to do
was make one youtube video about it
right
right so here we were thinking that we
got the deal of a lifetime
except for
one tiny little detail
for the next six
years that youtube video
was one of the first results
whenever anyone searched for searched on
youtube for phuket hotels
to date it has 578 000 views how much do
you think that was worth to the hotel
drop it in the chat how much do you
think that was worth to the hotel
right
a lot
and that's when we realized how much
power
we have as creators and it's not just
about the video views
it's about telling a real
story that people connect with
something by the way that brands have a
very hard time doing
so after that experience i doubled down
i was ruthless i would pitch any brand i
would cold email anyone
and i got better at it
i developed strategies
i would test
which subject lines got higher open
rates and i'd switch up my approach
and i treated it like
a business
right
and one of the most interesting things i
learned
was that
the big brands
the ones that have the big budgets are
not working with creators directly
they've hired
security
that's right it's their advertising
agency their pr agency their influencer
agency's job
to protect them from things like
your crappy pitch
but if you properly introduce yourself
get on the radar of them with a
compelling illustration of what you can
bring to the table for their client
well the next time they have an
opportunity to fly you to spain
to ride on the maiden voyage of their
freaking awesome new cruise ship
they're gonna think of you
oh and
there's one thing i forgot to mention
about this royal caribbean deal
they also paid us twenty thousand
dollars
okay
so in the next 20 minutes i'm gonna walk
you through how my wife and i have made
over three million dollars working with
brands to date and not only that i'm
going to share how i've helped hundreds
of other creators earn millions more
through an influencer marketing agency
that i run and i'm talking tactics that
you can take away and start using in
your creator business today to make more
money
okay drop it in the chat
does that sound good right you ready for
this
okay so
before we get started on that though
i can sense that there's some folks in
the audience who are thinking
i'm not a lifestyle influencer right my
content is just too niche right i don't
have followers no brand would ever want
to work with me this isn't going to work
for me
right anyone thinking that
it's totally reasonable i get it
but let me tell you quickly the story of
my friend mike
see
a very successful major wireless carrier
had approached my influencer marketing
agency with a problem they knew that
their products resonated with people in
the fire community right financial
independence retirement early anyone
familiar right
um so their products resonated in that
community but they were struggling to
find creators
uh who were unique who spoke to that
audience
so we went out there right we did some
digging and we found
mike
at the time he had less than 1
000 subscribers on youtube okay
1 000 subscribers on youtube okay but do
you want to know the reason that the
brand got so excited about working with
them
it's because mike didn't just talk about
budgeting
he talked about budgeting
for active duty
military that was his niche let me say
that again
active duty military budgeting so the
brand was thrilled
right they were stoked to pay him
and they didn't care at all
how many followers he had and do you
want to know why
because they turned around they used
that awesome video he made and they ran
a bunch of ads to reach other people
like him
powerful
right
see i used to think that
brand deals were unpredictable right
they're awesome when you can get them
but you can never really rely on that
income because you never know
when the next opportunity is going to
land in your inbox right
and that really sucks because according
to a recent study 68
of influencers say that brand
collaborations are their largest revenue
stream
right you're probably thinking
justin
that sample size is kind of small 526
creators really okay fine here is
another study with a sample size of 2
000 creators and this one says it's 77.3
right
so wouldn't it be awesome
if we could make this giant
bucket of money
and turn it into a predictable
income source
well the good news is that it's
predictable if you make it predictable
okay i've created a framework called the
sponsorship wheel
by actively consistently monitoring how
many brands you are interacting with at
each of these stages you will never
wonder again when
and where your next brand deal will come
from
by the way there is a reason that these
steps are not listed out in a horizontal
timeline
because when you get to step eight
you have to start all over again you
gotta pitch the same brand that you just
worked with on your next idea
so
regardless of whether you already have
inbound deal flow meaning brands are
already reaching out to you
okay
if you want to create consistent income
from sponsorships and keep this wheel
spinning that requires
sustained pitching
which means
that as creators we all have a common
enemy
and our enemy is our empty
scent folder
right
your inbox is something that you have no
control over
whether a brand decides to reach out to
you today or next week or never
that is simply out of your hands but
every single email right here in your
scent folder
you have full
control over and represents a new
opportunity to absolutely blow a brand's
mind with a unique creative
mutually beneficial and lucrative
sponsorship proposal
so
now that i've convinced you that
pitching is a worthwhile thing to do
let's talk about how to craft a killer
pitch that no brand will ignore okay and
i want to make sure you get your money's
worth okay so i'm going to give you an
excerpt from my course called brand deal
wizard and this is the pitching method
that i teach okay it's called the rope
method okay r stands for relevant to a
campaign that they're working on
o stands for organic
meaning that you can tie your pitch back
to content that you've already
posted
okay
p
stands for persistent meaning you email
regularly even if they're not responding
which can be tough
and e is easy to execute when they say
yes
so let's pretend we're pitching starkist
tuna let's try out this [ __ ]
hi i absolutely love your brand i'm
curious if you'd like to collaborate
justin
what do you think the brand's reaction
will be when you send them that email
drop it in the chat what do you what do
you think the brand's reaction is going
to be when you send them that email
what do you think
right
oh
right total snorefest
that's what every single creator says to
them
is that interesting in any way
let's check the rope method okay is this
relevant to a campaign that they're
working on
no
right does this tie back to organic
content that you've already posted
no
have you been persistent
well if you're sending
kind of crappy pitches like that
probably not and is this easy to execute
well if the brand responded and said
great sounds great let's do it what are
you gonna do
right you didn't propose anything so
instead
why don't we do a little research okay
i don't care whether you're on instagram
or not
okay
instagram is a research tool
wow interesting last may starkist was
talking about mediterranean diet month
interesting so
what you're going to do instead is make
an organic post
about the mediterranean diet
before you pitch them
you're going to get a bunch of amazing
comments that sweet engagement
right and then
you send them this hey stacy
just wanted to follow up because i
noticed that last spring starcus was
touting the benefits of the
mediterranean diet i have also been
posting about its benefits recently and
my audience is
hungry
for more do you like that pun i'm a big
fan of puns so right you're hung they're
hungry for more i would love to create
an ig reel and story showcasing circus
recipes that fit this plan
i can shoot and post within two weeks
i'll give you usage right through
december 31st
what do you think justin
well let's go through the rope checklist
right is this relevant to a campaign
that they're working on
probably
right see most creators think that that
brands reinvent the real every single
year with their marketing strategies and
that couldn't be further from the truth
they just kind of
dust off the old you know same old
marketing playbook from last year and
they run it again
so honing in on a campaign that you know
they love they ran it after all
right
you will instantly stand out and be
relevant to them
how about organic
well see that
that blue link
right there
that's where you linked
your last post that organic post you
made right they can click through they
can see all the amazing people all the
amazing things people are saying about
it right and they can immediately learn
more about your audience you're not
linking them your channel page
they're not going to watch 15 of your
videos they're going to watch 30 seconds
of one of them and be like yep this
person is a good fit
so
your organic content will convince them
that you already have affinity
for their brand which is critical
okay
how about persistent
right how about persistent
well it's kind of hard to visualize what
persistence looks like but let's just
say that when you put soul
into the words that you use
when there is intent
behind the ideas that you're proposing
being persistent and following up
it's just not as scary
right because
you know it's a good idea right and if
they don't want to take you up on it
that's their loss
i think a lot of times when
we don't hear back
from a brand that we pitched it's not
because we suck
right
it's not because our pitch sucked it's
because they're busy aren't you busy i'm
busy so are they
right so just give them some grace and
don't instantly turn inward when you
don't hear back
okay
you just have to hit them again next
week
and how about
easy to execute
well duh you told them exactly what
you'd do for them
now
you might be thinking yeah but what if
they don't want to do
the exact thing that i'm pitching
well i can almost guarantee you that
that's going to happen they'll say wow
this is a really cool idea you know
we're not really activating on that
platform right now but how about this
instead
right can you make a post on this other
platform is set that's a priority for us
right now
so the point is is that you gave them
something tangible that
they could react to
so yes this is easy to execute
and for those of you saying like uh
this seems like so much work
right i already feel like i'm on a
content hamster wheel trying to appease
the social media algorithm gods
i don't have time for this
well
2009 justin would have said the same
thing because
i had to send a hundred of these crappy
pitches
to get one or two responses this was the
spray and pray approach
right
contrast that with
2022 justin
where
if i put the time to do research on a
brain i'm talking 15 20 minutes max per
pitch
i will receive a response more than 50
of the time
let me say that again
i will receive a response more than 50
of the time i'm not making this up i
know that seems insane i'm not making it
up
here's some proof
molly says since i started the rope
method my success rate in pitching has
skyrocketed and brands are offering to
pay me way more money than they were
before
so
what do you think is the big takeaway
here
why are brands willing to pay molly more
when she uses the rope pitching method
well
it's because it's not about
you
what do i mean by that
see this is the challenge that every
brand is faced with their entire
business fails if they cannot figure out
creative ways to access their ideal
consumers
they have to cross this giant chasm
every single day
how is the brand going to do it well
they could try to jump across and risk
plummeting to their death or
they could choose the safer option which
is you
because you
are
the bridge
let me say that again
you are the bridge
by the way
correct me if i'm wrong but
you probably painstakingly built this
bridge with your bare hands over many
years right publishing over and over
commenting replying
and so are you gonna let any random
brand cross over your bridge
no
and you're most certainly not gonna let
them cross over your bridge for free
no they gotta pay you for that privilege
and by the way
it's not just the bridge that you're
charging for
it's this
that big old brain of yours because
when you craft a pitch that is rooted in
research
a deep understanding of what makes your
audience tick
and you're illustrating how you can help
them accomplish their marketing
objectives they will instantly think wow
this is not just another creator
and in fact
you're not just a creator
you're a consultant
actually
you're a production company in a box
y'all
you're the creative team you're the
camera crew you edit the content you
distribute the content you market the
content
and if the brand doesn't hire you
right
they have to go out there
and hire a production company
actors and actresses to star in the
content they have to hire someone to
edit the content
and then and then
when they finish the content they gotta
pay facebook
instagram and youtube to run the dang ad
so
the next time that you're feeling
impostor syndrome
nervously hovering over that send button
remember
that you
have
the power
because the point of a pitch
is not to get the deal
huh
let me say that again
the point of a pitch
is not
to get
the deal
i have done literally thousands of
sponsorships at this point so
i'm gonna give you a little peek behind
the scenes of how
paid influencer campaigns actually come
together
okay when you sent your random pitch on
may 4th let's say
and the brand says
i'm sorry we're not working with
creators on any paid campaigns right now
hey drop it in the chat has ever has
ever happened to you you reach out to a
brand you dm them they say oh sorry
we're not recruiting any you know don't
have any budget to work with influencers
on paid campaigns right now drop it in
the chat anyone
let me know
what they didn't tell you was that they
just finished recruitment for their
summer campaign a few days ago
ah well that sucks
right and see this is where most
creators give up they think oh man the
brand hates me i suck my pitch sucked
when in reality there was no way that
you could have known that they had just
finalized the creators for their next
campaign
but we absolutely cannot stop here
because what happens
on may 26th the brand is going to have
their next budget meeting where they try
to finalize all their plans and allocate
how much money each different department
gets
at that meeting the executive team is
going to ask the head of marketing hey
so
how much money are you allocating to our
tick tock strategy for the summer
campaign
the marketing team is going to look at
each other like
oh crap we don't have a tick tock
strategy
right and realize that in order to
appease their executive team they need
to reassess their strategy
right and then boom here you come
parachuting into their inbox on june
10th with an amazing article from adweek
which with case studies of how other
brands are killing it with short form
video content
you say hey thought you might find this
interesting
so then that article circulates amongst
the the marketing team and they're like
well we gotta call a meeting with our
internal team to talk about this article
that justin sent us you know we gotta
get our act together on tick tock
right
and then boom july 17th you hit him
again with an organic piece of content
on your platform with a little keyword
little
shout out to their brand of product hey
thought your team would enjoy this
little easter egg right
august 14th the brand's gonna have an
all hands marketing meeting where they
talk about the results and the learnings
from the summer campaigns
oh nice
i bet you know what's coming next right
you know what's coming next right boom
september 1st now you pitch them again
with a slightly revised version of your
initial pitch
and they're gonna say
thank you so much this is really helpful
we'll definitely be in touch oh man
then silence
until
september 20th when they finally get the
green light from their cfo
to increase their budget to include tick
tock on their fall marketing campaign
and surprise surprise who do you think
they're going to reach out to
they're going to reach out to this
creator that gave up way back here right
no they're not going to reach out to
that person they're going to reach out
to you because you were at the forefront
of their minds for the last four months
providing value
right
so
what i hope you see by now is that when
a brand ghosts you
or a brand says no
it's not no
it's not yet
and the point of a pitch
is not to get
it's not just to get the deal
the pitch is
step one
of the wheel
one final story from a creator named
caitlyn about the power of investing in
your knowledge and the impact that it
can have
on your business
i decided to quit my job back in january
of 2021 to be a full-time beauty content
creator i literally had no idea what i
was doing i was
severely under charging i was not even
reading through contracts but with the
help of creator wizard justice i now
know exactly what i'm doing i know how
to talk to brands i know how to pitch
myself i know how to negotiate i know
how to carefully read through contracts
i was making around 1400 to 2 000 a
month within two weeks two weeks i
signed over thirty thousand dollars
worth of contracts and now i am making
anywhere from forty to fifty thousand
dollars a month but i now know what i'm
doing as a full-time beauty content
creator and you have literally changed
my life
now
i want to give a small caveat that
caitlyn
she has a million followers on tick tock
and i'm sure you're thinking okay yeah
if i had a million followers i could
probably make a lot of money too but
extrapolate this example for your own
creator business if you could 2 3 4 5 x
what you're making right now at your
current following with your current
content
that would be hugely impactful
right
so
i would love for you all to take the
next step which is the 14 day brand deal
challenge so i've teamed up with think
media to create a completely free
training completely free training with
daily emails for 14 days
teaching you how to get your next or
first
brand deal you just need to go to
thinkbranddeals.com
that's thinkbranddeals.com
to sign up
today so
i would love to take some questions this
is like one of my favorite parts um and
i was a blast being here
oh my goodness thank you so much justin
i was taking notes and there was one
thing that i loved uh that you talked
about and that was that and i always say
this to our team the fortune is in the
follow up it's not usually in the first
pitch it's always in the follow-up and
if there's one thing i hope that people
got from today's session it's that one
you've got to be strategic but two
it is about that persistence and the
consistency that you're doing so thank
you so much for bringing that we do have
some questions that came in um but
before we get to those justin where can
people find you uh if they want to work
with you on a deeper level um obviously
go to thinkbranddeals.com but you're
over here crushing it on youtube as well
right
i am yeah my youtube channel it's called
creator wizard um and this is literally
the only thing i talk about i only talk
about sponsorships and brand deals talk
about a niche i know you guys talk about
that a lot right it's like when i really
dialed dialed into this thing that
really is my expertise in my wheelhouse
i'm just kind of having so much fun
about it and the beauty of picking a
niche is that once i actually be like
you know what all i'm gonna talk about
is sponsorship i now can think of like a
thousand videos just about this subject
because i literally will never get tired
of talking about it and what what i hope
you saw from my my presentation in this
talk was that there's a lot of subtlety
and a lot of interest intricacy that
goes into uh you know the actual process
of working with brands not just the
execution of the deal when you actually
sign on the dot line but prior to that
right like what's actually happening uh
in advance before they actually reach
out there's so much that happens behind
the scenes and so yeah just a creator
wizard i'm pretty much at creator wizard
everywhere on social media and uh yeah i
would love for you to join uh the 14 day
brand deal challenge it's free guys come
on 14 day daily emails for you i
guarantee you by the end of this thing
you're going to be so hyped yes i have
our entire marketing team going through
it also because uh lifelong leaders are
lifelong learners and i love to learn
from experts just like you so we did
have some questions that came in and i
think this one is definitely relevant
because you know it is it we cannot say
that quote unquote this is easy
especially when it comes to the emotions
that come with valuing yourself and
presenting yourself to a brand don uh
rimmel uh he is um one of our inner
circle students and his question is how
do you work through having doubt of your
value to a brand and underselling your
uh position for example requesting only
products and not money and i know that
this is a huge struggle for a lot of
creators because one this is actually
still an emerging industry like you were
like you were sharing but also we no one
teaches us how much we should charge or
what what is our value and so how do you
even assess that and i know you go
deeper into that inside of what you
offer but tell us just a little bit
about the doubts that come with it and
how you can how you can assess your
value
yeah you know don it's a really great
question and one that i get a lot it's
very common um and so first and foremost
um is to not be too hard on yourself i
think that's the like like heather was
mentioning you know it really is a lot
of us are shooting blind when my wife
and i first got into this industry in
2009 that was when we started our first
channel if you can believe it um like i
mentioned um like we had no idea what we
were doing it was the wild west we made
every mistake in the book you know we
did deals without signing contracts we
um you know gave away broadcast tv like
one time we had um we turned on the tv
and we had i saw a brand was like
running an ad on tv a commercial with
footage from my wife's youtube channel
and we were just like we went back and
looked at the contract and like sure
enough yep we signed away those rights
without even getting compensated for it
right so we literally have made every
mistake in the book so first and
foremost like don't be too hard on
yourself like this is we are all
learning even not today i'm learning uh
you know every day i'm trying to like
break into tic toc right now almost uh
just over six thousand followers right
so i'm trying to we're all trying to
reinvent ourselves right with these new
content formats and things like that too
um and so my biggest piece of advice
about you know how to understand how to
value yourself is that understand that
um it's not always about your numbers i
think that that's what a lot of creators
are fixated on because that's where uh
their their mindset is all day long it's
like growing their channel growing their
following growing their viewership their
engagement and so on um but
the biggest mindset unlock there and
shift is that most a lot of brands don't
care at all about your numbers right
because that's not the value that they
see from you right so for example if
there is i don't know don if you can let
me know in the chat what the what your
niche is um but like there are so many
brands who um actually look to creators
for their own expertise about content
creation and how to succeed on social
media so now instead of your pitch when
you reach out to them don being like hey
i'm going to talk about you on my
youtube channel i'm going to do an
integrated video and an amplification on
uh you know social media or whatever
like that's the majority of like 99.9
percent of creators that's their pitch
right like wouldn't it be interesting if
you pitched them was hey like i
absolutely love your brand i notice that
you don't have an active presence on
your youtube channel
i would love to create a series for you
let's just say you're like a rv like
outdoor influencer um creator on youtube
right you could say let's say you're
pitching rei or some outdoor company or
camping equipment or something
i would love to create a series on your
youtube channel where it's me and a
bunch of other outdoor creators rv life
creators van life creators sitting
around and talking about life and what
it's like being uh you know on the road
and raising a family and all that stuff
yeah we got all this rei gear around us
but we're not like we're plugging the
product we're sitting around a campfire
i'm bringing other people on the show i
will produce that show for you it will
live on your channel we can turn it into
a podcast
yes it's going to be 5 000 a month but
that is my proposal
do you see how fundamentally different
of a proposal and a pitch that is
right and so oftentimes understanding
your value and worth is it's so like
dependent upon the particular brand that
you're pitching that's why it's so it's
so difficult for me to be like this is
your value don right i don't know your
channel i don't know your page but what
i what i hope everyone hears today is
that your value is different to every
brand which is why you need to be
charging different rates to every brand
right so that's the kind of the the
succinct answer to that um but i hope
that helps
yeah and i want to just add a little bit
to that justin because um coming from my
background wasn't marketing first and so
coming from a space where i saw that
there are dollars there are a lot of
dollars and and available to be used in
marketing ways um when it comes to
actually like how much do i quote charge
here's what i say name your number where
it makes sense for you to spend time
doing it and then add 10 out of fear why
because there's always negotiation in
numbers if someone comes back to you and
they're like sorry that's way out of our
budget and you've given them a full
proposal then you can actually come back
and say great well what out of that
would you like to see and let's
negotiate that maybe they're like i
actually don't want youtube videos and
tick tock all i want is one youtube
video and then you can negotiate from
there but oh i always say add 10 out of
fear because what's surprising is that
some brands will come back and say great
and you're like shoot i could have done
20 out of fear right and you can always
negotiate up from or you can always
negotiate down from a higher number but
it's hard to go to it's hard to start at
a number and then go increase it's much
easier to start at a number and then
decrease and i've i've known that to be
my experience you know heather i would
probably take it a step further and be
like at 100 to your rate like i i think
that as as creators like we're so
fearful of here here's here's the thing
i think like
like saying the first number that's the
biggest thing is like oh i wish i could
just like a lot obviously first and
foremost you should ask the brand their
budget what is your budget right because
a lot of brands will tell you right and
like wait really they're going to tell
me how much they're going to pay me
right yeah and the reason is that this
campaign has to go live in 10 days we
can pay you 2 000 can you turn this
around right a lot of times that's
that's really the way it is right it's
time sensitive um but again what i have
found over the years like coaching
hundreds of creators is that uh like the
vast majority of creators are way under
charging not just 10 more like 100 200
500 what they actually should be because
um you know we can we can go i want to
answer some more questions but like yeah
this is a very critical concept you just
have to kind of shoot your shot
sometimes yeah all right let's get to
this one here and then we're going to
jump into hot seats inside of our inner
circle so if you are not a part of our
inner circle already we do a monthly
membership program here at think media
you can go to think innercircle.com to
get more information we actually do an
extensive q a and hot seats which we
will do after we answer this uh question
which is how many subscribers i know you
touched on this and this is always a
question that we get here at think media
how many subscribers do you need in
order to do x and i'd love for you to
just explain this from your vantage
point as someone who is working with
brands and how you said before numbers
don't really matter but actually there
are some numbers that do matter
yeah no i hear you and so i do i have a
video on my youtube channel called how
to get sponsorships with zero
subscribers
because i wanted to make a very
hyperbolic video because um to
really like hammer home this point that
your subscribership is completely
irrelevant yes there are some brands out
there who are like oh you have to have
at least 10 000 subscribers to work with
us like yeah that's not going to be your
tribe that's not going to be the brand
you know not going to be your ideal
brand partner um because going back to
this whole idea around understanding the
goal of the campaign it's so critical
because um at that point let's let's for
example say that uh you pitch a brand
right or a brand reaches out to you
and uh you ask them what would success
look like
for this campaign that that is the
number one question that i advise all
creators that i coach to be asking at
the at the very outset of a conversation
okay because when they come back to you
and they say oh well you know success to
us is we actually just love the way like
your presence on video and we would love
to just get a bunch of content from you
that we can repurpose
we can put it on our website we can use
it on our social media platforms we can
use it for paid advertising right that's
what they find
that's what they see success as right so
then your pitch to them should not be
oh i'm gonna do an integration on my
youtube channel i'm gonna do you know
post on my instagram and make you some
real no they don't care they just told
you they don't care right and so at that
point it does not matter how many
subscribers you have at all because that
and the other reason that that's awesome
is that your rate is now detached
from your following it's detached from
your subscribers right and so it's it's
this mindset shift is so critical
because again it's not about your
subscribership it's it's about
understanding how you can help the brand
win
how can you help them win separate from
your own channel your own presence
because there is so much value in
you know your presence on camera you
know utilizing your name and likeness in
advertising again there's so many other
ways in which you can provide value to
brands that have nothing to do with your
subscribership
so so good well justin thank you so much
for uh helping us with that we're going
to jump into
our inner circle hot c and q a so if
you'd like to be a part of that you can
go to think innercircle.com uh you can
jump into what we are doing over uh here
at think media and we're gonna head
right over um to that right now so we
will see you over there in just a second